Okay.
Hey Man, what's going on? Oh,
Yay.
Fucking freckled cunt.
It's the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday and
Monday morning podcast.
[inaudible] just checking in on you.
Oh,
Billy's burning it at fucking
both ends do to, to, to, to do,
do you know I woke up this morning by
Dubai [inaudible] poop and I went to the
gym by that and I that and I did so bad
pull downs and I had to leave with a
grin cause I got it out of the way up.
I was going back and forth with somebody,
um,
this morning and east coast friend of
mine who I hadn't talked to in a while.
How are you enjoying being a dad
and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then she hits me up with the
whole, hey, I'm turning 50 this year.
I am not happy about it. I said,
yeah, I turned 50 last year. She goes,
how was turning 50 for you? You
know, she goes, you're a guy.
You probably don't care.
It's much harder for a woman,
especially with our careers. Oh,
did I have fun with that? You know,
I just wrote back,
wow.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You know what I mean?
White women complaining is
one of the funniest fits.
Like you got to fucking house in a
beautiful family. What is the fucking per,
it's so much harder for me. You're going
to outlive me by six to eight years.
So me turn in 50s, like
me turn in like 56, 57 58.
You don't hear me complaining.
You know,
you never hear me complain on this
podcast. This is nothing but positivity,
rainbows and fucking UNICORNS. Um, yeah,
I love that Shit. It's harder for,
it's harder for women to go to the gym.
It's harder for us to lose weight. Well
then fucking work harder. You know,
everybody's different. Oh, is that where
it's hard and you know, it was, you know,
it's harder for me,
uh,
trying to get some woman to pay the
cover charge and buy me drinks. You know,
it's harder for me to divorce court,
uh, outliving you. I mean, the, it,
it balances out ladies.
Getting child support. Yeah,
that's harder for me because
I'll be the one paying it.
Then all of a sudden it costs 900 grand
a month to raise a fucking two year old.
Right. I just don't understand the
constant complaining by white women.
Okay, you're white, you live
in America. Shut up. Okay,
wait to the other problems is
solved and then we'll get to you.
You're at the meat counter. Your
number isn't up yet. Wait your turn.
Alright, wait your turn
Abigail. Chino but hard.
It's so much easier for you to go to.
It's not easier.
Men's lives are harder because
we have to live with you guys.
Oh Man.
I want to become friends with a lesbian
couple and I want to like be friends
with like the, the, the, the chicken,
the relationship that's got to
handle more the dude shit. You know,
cause you know,
opposites attract.
And I would think even like in
the lesbian community there,
there's gotta be somebody you know
who's out there swinging the ax,
getting the fucking firewood while the
other ones there making the muffins.
That's the lesbian I want to talk to
right into my podcast. Please. You know,
I want to know if those lesbians
on average die sooner than,
than, than the, the, the
dainty lesbian, you know.
Okay.
The lesbian who's got to go out on the
fucking roof and adjust the fucking
directv satellite fucking thing
in the middle of the fucking rain.
That's all I want to.
That's who I want to hear from.
That's the study I would be
doing. Um, anyways, uh, Geez,
I'm coming in hot. I'm coming in hot.
I'm wearing my old man's sweater that I,
that I've got when I was over there in
Ireland, you know, and I'll tell you,
that was so much harder for women to
find sweaters, you know, to be judged.
Um, anyway, speaking of which,
I'm in the middle of an acting gig right
now and I am having the time of my life.
I'm having so much fun in this acting gig.
It's actually scaring me because
most of the time comedians,
the entire time you're on the acting
Gig, you'll be in like, you know,
I could have fucking made you know twice
as much money in one hour that I have
that I'm going to on this entire fucking
shoot. You know, why am I still here?
That's what you usually think at.
But uh, I've, I've cracked the code.
Yeah,
I know how to do it now.
What I do is when I go on to set,
I don't bring my phone and I don't bring
a watch and then it's like I walked
into a casino. I don't know if its
day, I don't know if it's night.
I just fucking do my shit.
I tried to do it, you know,
as well as I can,
I listened to the director or whatever.
And then in between takes I sit down
and just conserve my fucking energy and
that's all I do.
Not Looking at anything.
I just sit there like fucking private
pile when he's sitting on the commode
in full metal jacket.
And then now all of a sudden after
I feel like I've been at two hours,
all of a sudden it's okay, we'll
break for lunch. I'm like, okay.
And then I go outside into the sun.
You know,
I get a salad with the protein ladies
salad with the protein heavy on the salad
protein,
no bigger than the size of my pasty palm.
That's what I do.
And then I just fucking go back in and I
just do it all over again and I have no
fucking idea what time it is. And then
all of a sudden they just say, you rapped.
And I just act like a silly jackass
and try to make jokes all day long.
And I have been having the fucking
time of my life having a great time.
Um, so anyways, what am I acting
on? I'm not allowed to tell.
It's a secret. Um, I'm
acting on general hospital.
Everybody. Okay? I've come back from the
dead. I, a lot of people don't know this.
I had a role on that back in the 80s when
I had a giant orange fucking Afro and
a, my character died of cancer.
But now he's come back it,
you know, his hair didn't grow
back yet, but his beard didn't.
And that's the jump off
point to the character.
And I am going to go out on a limb
and say this is going to be the most
interesting character since
heath ledger's the joker. Okay.
I am the heath ledger joker character of,
of general hospital.
Okay.
It's an 87 episode arc that we
shoot over the course of one week.
I don't know what I'm talking about
anymore. Uh, you know, and you know,
I'll tell you what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about two and three shows
after this acting Gig is over to get
myself ready to shoot my next special,
I'm going to be in Santa Barbara,
Santa Barbara, where all the rich
white people in Oprah moved after they,
after they made money in Hollywood.
All right?
Then I'm going to Pasadena. All
right. We're all the racist,
right wing lunatics,
you know,
build a fucking wall of la live.
A lot of people don't realize that.
A lot of people think everybody out
here is a liberal area. That's not true.
All you gotta do is just go to
Burbank, okay? They're walking around.
They got fucking two by fours
and pitchforks. You know,
I believe the kids say shit gets real in
Burbank and then I'm out in Riverside.
Okay. Riverside, that part of America,
you know that politicians don't bring up.
You know that feminists don't bring up
when they're attacking standup comedians
x, they forget. What about all
the poor people in Riverside?
Riverside.
That's just sounds like a place where
you can dump a body and you know what?
That's exactly what happens.
If you ever kill anybody in Los Angeles,
you have to know their next move.
Okay.
Other than getting rid of your cell
phone is you drive the body to Riverside.
Okay. As far as I know, there is no
river there. Okay? I don't know what,
I don't know what it is,
but all I know there's,
there's enough gullies and there's just
enough dead people there already that
you can get lost in the herd with
dragging your dead body. Okay.
Um, I will be performing there.
Santa Barbara on February 15th,
the day after the most bullshit
fucking holiday there is the,
you never hear a fucking, you
know, peep out of your wife, bitch.
You see here what my fucking
wife's asking, hey man, did she,
she asked for this fucking
stupid designer goddamn bag.
I swear to God it looked like somebody
dumped toothpaste all over it. You know,
like,
you know,
like when some fucking jackass partners
up with some high end label to do their
version of the bag,
you know,
and then every fucking bored
fucking Douche bag has to
go get the fucking thing.
You know, not say my wife's board, I love
her. I just, I just, I looked at the bag,
I'm like, you look at that fucking
thing that did that. It's not getting,
what are you going to do with that thing?
I like it. I think it's interesting.
It's bold. It's fucking ugly as
shit. I wish you could see this bag.
Do you remember those stupid fucking
toothpaste that came out that was like
toothpaste, mouthwash and
deodorant all at the same time?
It looked like a fucking rainbow.
Just imagine if you did that,
but it,
but it was also like cloudy,
like milk and you dump
that on a beautiful,
yeah.
Gorgeous handmade fucking bag.
That was perfectly fucking fine.
You know what is art? You can't judge
art. Yeah, you can't. That stinks.
Okay. Fucking stinks. You know, that's,
that begs for like, people who like,
you know, like John Michael
[inaudible], you know,
like the hacky artists that
everybody knows. You know,
people just like to say is guys name,
just so they can make it
sound like they fucking,
they can speak French Shawn
Michael Basket. You don't
just fucking stick figures.
I mean, I fucking drew like
that in the first grade.
Yeah.
I had,
I can't believe how much all this pictures
I put on my parents' refrigerator.
How much should they be worth nowadays?
Um, I'm fucking with you. I don't,
this one thing I don't know anything
about at, and if you don't believe me,
just watch my act,
but I really don't.
I don't know why.
Okay.
Um,
I don't get Andy Warhol.
Okay.
Just painting the tomato soup
can every was like, oh my God,
he's commented on commercialism in
America. All right, great comment. Uh,
how much is,
how much for fucking can of soup and
that canvas that you fucking put it on?
I'll give you that amount of money
for it. Um, anyways, by the way,
you know, that guy got shot by
a woman. I didn't know that.
And then she did like fucking three weeks
in jail and then got out for the rest
of his fucking life.
He's got to deal with this crazy sell
would sell running around out there.
And then like 20 years later,
you kind of died of complications
from getting shot by her. No,
but it's so much harder for a woman.
MMM. Anyways, yeah. I
don't understand. You know,
the one guy I actually liked liked it,
that I kind of understood and it's
not cause I kind of look like the uh,
bald version of him. I didn't
mind Van Gogh. Oh really?
Bill, you didn't mind him.
Did you allow him in your artistic world?
I didn't mean it like that.
The guy who used the lines,
you know,
the vertical lines and he painted
shit like that. Uh, I liked that shit.
I Dunno. I like when somebody paints
somebody, how they look, you know,
now when they stick their ear and
their forehead and it's like, whoa man.
Like why do you think he did that?
You know?
Is that because he feels like nobody
can hear his thoughts? I mean,
is there are layers to this? Uh, no.
I just think he fucking knows how to draw
an ear and he stuck it on the forehead.
He's probably dropping
acid. I don't know. Or,
or even all those canvases where it's
just, it's, it's nothing. It's just,
it looks like some toddler just
fucking smeared it all over the place.
He's just like, yeah, just like, why,
you know, I just look at him like,
why did he put that color over there?
Like why is that?
I saw Laura's one time and some Metallica
documentary and he was selling this
fucking this fucking pay too.
Cause he was getting all this money for,
he was just going,
I just like that over there is just like,
why did he put that cock?
Like I don't know Lars,
I've got to go out on a limb.
I think you could have done that.
The saved yourself a bunch of money.
But he turned around and he sold it
and he made even more fucking money.
And you combine that with the fact that
he gets his drum kits for free in what
you have is a very rich young man.
Um,
anyways, how much time is
that? 12 minutes. Fuck,
I got another fucking 17 and a half
to go. Jesus fucking Christ. You know,
some days this podcast,
you know,
it just goes by quick and other times
it doesn't. Did Anybody Watch uh,
barstool sports at the fucking super
bowl man? How fucking fun was that?
They got into the, uh, the, uh,
the fucking press conference
and Portnoy was asking,
uh, Gee, I don't know any of the names.
Still the rams running back wide took
a knee and how it cost them like four
grand on a bed
and then what the NFL is going to
fucking kick them out. It's like that.
They're all about gambling. They have
sports gambling now. It's just like,
you know,
it's their dirty little secret.
You might as well just let fans
ask those questions. Right.
I thought it was fucking hilarious.
And the only thing funnier than that
was afterwards when Portnoy did his
interview or what I was interviewing
thing and he was all fucking amped up
saying like, what were they
gonna do to me? And he goes,
put the fucking cuffs on me.
Okay.
It's
all good. Like he's fucking snake plis
skin. What the fucking cops on me.
I didn't know he was like
that. Steven Seagal. Dave
Portnoy's, I'm telling you, man,
you put them in a prison. Evidently
they're going to take over. Um,
but anyways,
I thought that was really funny.
And then he went on fucking the new show
there with that fucking Weirdo looking
guy. That guy, he always
goes on, that guy's show,
that guy who looks like you know,
he the guy who killed his girlfriend
accidentally cause they were having rough
sex, doesn't he look like
one of those guys? Um,
and he was still wearing the costume that,
you know,
God bless those guys at fucking, at
a bar stool. You know what I mean?
How boring is the week between the AFC
and NFC championship game and the Super
Bowl, you know, put the cuffs on
me, put the lotion at the pocket.
Um, oh, by the way, now the Ruffin
rally is coming up order that,
that's gotta be a in
Atlanta. And um, you know,
I heard, I didn't realize they said
Portnoy was banned from all NFL events.
I don't know how many years ago,
but he's still allowed to buy a
ticket to the Superbowl and go, right.
You know, is he allowed to do that or
are they going to be sitting there?
Do they have this security?
All right, this is Dave.
Looks like without a fake
mustache hanging off his face.
And this is what he looks like now with
it on. Um, I wonder how that works.
I wonder. These are the things that I
think about. All right. What are we up to?
15 minutes, just like that,
15 minutes, just like that.
Um, so anyways, I went to the
gym this morning, right as
that woman was texting me,
telling me how hard it was for her
to turn 50. You know what I mean?
It was so difficult.
I just can't imagine being in a white
woman having to blow out all those candles
in your beautiful house.
I mean, God, you know,
maybe you ought to think
about the children that put
those candles together in a
sweatshop. Um, you know,
they probably have to do that with their
one arm after they dug up some diamonds
for you. I want that. Why? Um,
all right. Anyways, hey bill, do you
have any super bowl predictions? Yes,
I'm going to age 100 fucking years.
Once again,
I am having a small select group
of people come over and uh,
I'm going simple, by the way. Anybody
who's hosting a super bowl party,
all right,
don't let anybody talk you into
getting this all this fucking food.
All right? Nobody throws an event
like my lovely wife. All right?
But the thing about it is,
is afterwards you left with a bunch of
stuff and then you have to eat it because
you don't want it to go bad.
And then like, you know,
whatever you enjoyed by the
last time we had a thing.
I think it was for my daughter's
birthday is hilarious. She turned two.
So we had a two and under party, right?
Instead of 21 and over, you know,
two and under. So he had all these
little kids there and then like whatever.
So we had 10 kids. It's going
to be 20 parents there, right.
Provided it's not a broken home.
Um, so we had to have all, you know,
fucking Bagels, Sam like
locks, all of this shit, dude.
I was eating a fucking salmon
for like eight fucking days.
I mean, I just have two words. It's just
like, you know, because, oh, that's right.
So now I'm having my
Superbowl party and he goes,
why don't you get a caterer referred?
I say,
cause I don't want to be eating fucking
hotdogs for like the next 12 days.
So I just, you know, I figured, all right,
the most anybody's going to eat is two
burgers each the biggest I'm going to
make the burgers probably a quarter
pound. Right? That's another thing too,
when you make the homemade burgers, don't
make them fucking gigantic. All right?
You can't make them check canted take.
It's just, it becomes too much. All right,
you got to make them like the same way
Miller high life makes their beers,
somehow it's 12 ounces,
but if feels like fucking four
and it just goes down easy.
That's what you want to do.
Cause then they'll come back and
then they'll get the second one.
You know what I mean? Uh, yet bill, it's
very simple. Your theory is very simple.
So I'm trying to, uh, like
have the least amount,
you know, and just some chips and
some beer. And some fucking cigars.
And the great fucking thing
is that this is a very,
very sexist Superbowl party in
that it's men only. All right?
So they're not going to give a fuck.
Burgers and dogs,
they're in a little bit of chips.
They bring the booze and I get the
cigars and then I'm good. I'm out.
I'm fucking out. All right. Worst thing
I got to do is I gotta wash fucking,
you know,
five to 10 plates and the Shit I used
on my flat top grill who gives a fuck.
And then I'm out and I'm when I'm hoping
is in the end that you're in a wiggle
of Patriots have won their sixth
uh,
Super Bowl Championship. So we'll
have six super bowl championships,
zero AFL titles,
zero AFL NFL championships
and no NFL championships.
MMM.
Maybe it's because maybe this is what I,
I,
here's another theory have about why
they don't count NFL championships.
Maybe because the AFL at
first was this upstart league.
Everybody laughed at the League
and then
they got better and better and better to
the point the NFL actually had to have
a championship game with them to show
that they were the superior league,
which they did for the first two years.
And then the third year they lost
because they played Earl moral instead of
fucking Johnny Unitas.
Some people say so they actually proved
that they were on par or at least good
enough to win one out of every
three championship games.
And at that point they were like,
what are we doing here?
Why don't we just merge
and we'll start over again.
But having said all that,
it was still called the NFL.
So maybe that's why they do it.
But I think it's unbelievably
disrespectful to Sam Huff,
Bobby Lane, Frank Gifford,
all of these, Jim Brown,
all of these amazing hall of
Famers to act as though like,
you know,
to not bring up the championships within
those franchises that they played for
that have wreaked havoc on their
bodies that shorten their lives,
that you don't even bring it up. I just
think it's fucked up bill. We get it.
Jesus Christ.
You've made the point.
How about you read some advertising so
we can laugh at your inability to read
out loud? Fine, fine. I'll do it. You
don't think I'll fucking do it? Oh,
fuck it. I'll give him my wife. So much
shit about fucking Valentine's Day.
I'm like, I'm not getting you
shit this year is your year.
What are you going to do
for me? Huh? She goes,
what do you want for Valentine's
Day? I go, I want you to shut up.
I know I'm an asshole. She left him. She
knows him a dick. You know what I mean?
She knows what she married.
She now she married an
asshole like butcher box.
Butcher butcher box delivers 100%
grass fed and grass finished beef.
Oh, this is great for your
Superbowl party. Free Range.
Organic chicken and the the the the
the pinnacle of all murdered animals.
Heritage bread.
Pork.
Yeah.
Isn't bread B. R. E. D. B. R. E. E.
D is breed heritage breed pork.
Is that what it is?
Have I been saying that wrong
the entire fucking time?
Don't you love when you look up how to
pronounce something and then it's like,
it's not,
it's like that white robot guy just trying
to figure out how to say the name of
this person. And then I got us the APP APP
out there. Uh, all right, pronunciation.
It is breed. I've been, let me try.
Oh, it's a lady. Oh, it's about time.
All these robot ladies had been suffering
for so long. Let's hear that again.
Fried Fried,
fried.
Fried,
So what is breed?
Okay,
I thought bread was breg. Now that looks
stupid. I'm the worst speller ever. Uh,
the incredible quality of butcher box
meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and
free of antibiotics and hormones.
Before there were assassinated.
You know, if I was actually,
if I was working at a slaughterhouse,
I would like,
I would build like a fucking clock tower
and I'd have like the gun scope with
the hat turned around backwards.
I would just do that.
I'd go Oswald on him.
A cook with the peace,
peace of mind knowing you are eating
healthy and have all the cows running
around. We got a shooter, you know,
running for cover, high quality meat.
Each box comes with at least
eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual
size meals. But if you're a woman,
you're not allowed to eat that.
But
you can choose from five different
box types. All beef, beef and chicken,
beef and pork,
mixed box for the liberals.
Custom box for the Conservatives.
Just give me whatever I'm picking
out my own mic. This is America.
You want my meat? Kind of get it. I
said, come and get it mother fucker.
You get to to the fucking neck.
Um,
my favorite butcher block
cut is heritage breed pork.
I think bread sounds better.
Yeah, because I like toast.
Announce, announcing our brand,
our new brand of protein.
Uh, wild. You can't even
believe what I was going to say.
Dead feminist foot. Yes.
Run over at a rally.
So announcing our new bread brand,
brand of protein,
wild Alaskan Salmon, salmon,
salmon, butcher box sources.
They're pure sustainably
harvested salmon from Bristol Bay,
Alaska. Unlike any salmon
you'll find in your local store.
Literally,
it's red color means that this salmon
is as fresh as nutrient rich as it gets.
Okay? And rather than you having
to take a trip up there to get it,
some other person is going to catch it
for you and deliver it right to your God
damn door.
The same person who caught it is going
to show up and is all yellow fucking rain
coat with that look in his face, gets the
boat almost capsized during the storm.
You know,
and you won't even be able to look
them in the eye because you're not even
nearly the merit of years.
For $20 off your first box and two
pounds of free salmon, go to butcher
box.com/bird [inaudible],
B u r,
r that's butcher box.com/burr
and enter [inaudible] B u.
R. R. Oh look who's left? Everybody.
Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness.
Jollies shave club.
Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best and you never
have to go to the store again. You know,
it's funny, I'm all out of one wipe
Charlies and up to in Paris to order more.
This Guy Shit in his,
uh,
that's because they deliver everything
you need right to you do and they keep
you fully stocked on what
you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works. By the way, one
wipe Charlie is not accurate. Okay?
You don't just do one wipe.
What it is is you used the toilet paper
first and then the one wipe Charlie gets
rid of any evidence that
anything went down. Okay?
It's like the poor man's per day.
Okay? You heard it here first.
You're probably going
to hear it here last.
Just make sure I get some sort of credit.
Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to get ready.
No matter what you're getting ready for.
They have you covered head to toe
for your hair. Hey, your skin,
your face, you name it, they have it.
And they have this new program where
they automatically keep you stocked up on
the products you use.
You determine what you want and when
you want it and it shows up right.
It should door. Uh, well Jesus Christ,
I hope you get out and exercise.
If it's that easy,
do they ever go white for your
underneath your mandated from one,
some for one from once a month to once
every six month plus with their handsome
discount. Hi fellows. The more
you buy, the more you save.
And Right now dollar shave club has a
bunch of starters sets you can try for
just $5, like their oral
care kit. After that,
the restock box ships regular sized
products@regularpricegetsyoustatussetforjustfivedollarsrightnowatdollarshaveclub.com
slash Burr B u. R. R, that's dollar shave
club.com/burb B. U. R. R.
All right and with that,
let's talk super bowl for
the final three and a half
Matte Buddha. Um, I don't know
what the fuck's going to happen.
I have this,
I kind of feel like it's going to be,
I feel he's going to be like a lot of
these NFL games where you've got two high
powered offenses and
they're going to be like,
this is going to be a high scoring game
and I think it's going to be low scoring
for the first half and then it's
just going to be a fucking shit show
in the second half and it's
going to be one of those things.
Whoever has the ball last wins,
you know,
or it could be like last
Superbowl where the defenses are,
are a complete non factor.
And to the point,
all that has to happen is your,
if whatever defense makes a play,
you just need to make one fucking
play and then, and then boom,
then you win the game.
That's what I think.
That's what I think cause I think last
year Superbowl rather than being one of
the ugliest fucking games
I've ever watched in my life,
I literally felt like I was watching
a third grade pop Warner game with the
complete lack of fucking
defense in that game. I, I, uh,
I am now realized that
that was not an anomaly,
that that is now the
way the game is played.
And that's the way it has to be played.
Because if you don't,
then these poor people that are playing
the fucking game or are going to,
you know, have this CTE
shit. So I've accepted it.
That's the way it is. And
uh, you know, I dunno,
that's just, I don't know. So, uh,
that, that, that is my feeling. I am,
I'm not believing on any level that
Todd Gurley isn't gonna play in,
is not gonna, you know,
fucking get a bunch of yards.
And I also feel like their quarterback,
whatever his fucking name is, I forget.
Um, he doesn't give a fuck that it's
a super bowl. He's going to come out.
They're cool as a cucumber.
I will say this about all
these new fucking quarterbacks.
They don't give a shit that
they're in the Superbowl. You know,
nick falls last year either. He was like,
he was playing catch in the backyard.
The first ball he threw, it was
like, this guy doesn't give a fuck.
This is going to be a long day. Uh,
loved nick false. I'm trying to think.
The last time I saw a quarterback
get look nervous, they just come.
I am a rookie. I threw 50
touchdowns. Patrick, my home's,
hey you want 50 more? Hey,
who wants to score next?
Fucking thrown it sidearm and shit.
They don't give a fuck.
They're all coming in like Clint Eastwood
in the Spaghetti Westerns, you know,
staring at three guys with your little
fucking cigarette, you know, Cigar Rela,
whatever the fuck he used to smoke.
They just come in and they just fucking,
they just light him up. So I think,
um, yeah. So I have no prediction.
I just hope my team's going to win.
I haven't watched enough football to
even remotely try to break the game down.
All I can do is break down
when I'm going to be doing,
which was making burgers and dogs and
not sitting down and pacing the entire
time.
But uh,
I think it's cool that the rams are back
in La and that got the blue and yellow
helmets. I liked that shit.
Oh, the blue and white.
I guess they went back to the one
they had in the 60s, but, uh, um,
I liked that shit.
And I think the Raiders should stay in
Oakland even though moving to Vegas is
going to be a great thing.
Oh, this can be a great thing.
Can you imagine how many people like
their last thing they're going to do after
they kill their wife in Vegas is to go
to a Raiders game before they're let out
in cuffs at halftime. I mean, it's going
to be like, it's gonna happen a lot,
you know, or choke a hooker or
whatever the fuck they going to do.
And that seedy little town,
the fucking nerve or the NFL to throw out
Dave Portnoy for asking that gambling.
I guess it's cause he didn't have a,
uh,
you didn't have a parking pass or whatever
the fuck you need to get into that
thing. Um, anyways,
but I just think it's so funny how much
they fucking annoyed and irritate the
NFL. They're sitting there acting
like they're a decent organization.
All the shit, all the fucking crap
that they've done. Um, I love it.
I love her. So God, God blessed
the fellas over at Barstool sports.
Um, all right, so what is it here? It's a,
there's your half hour.
Put the fuck off of me.
Yeah,
I run a sports website, but I'm fucking
cops on me. I'll take over the prison.
I would have been the exact opposite.
Please don't put them on me. I'm sorry.
Um, all right, that is the
podcast. Please enjoy, uh, the,
the music here and then the greatest
hits and all that shit coming up.
Another half hour of fucking stuff
here. And then, uh, have a Thursday,
another half hour of a former shelf
that I did about a Thursday afternoon
podcast. And everybody, I will, I'm
getting ready. Oh, Billy's getting ready.
He can't read the word bread or breed.
He's getting ready to do with special. So,
um, um, where are you
doing? You're special.
I should do take my special
at a woman's college.
Uh, I'm doing Santa Barbara, Pasadena,
Riverside tickets on sale now.
Um, on February 15th,
16th, 17th, Santa Barbara,
Pasadena Riverside where you're opening
ex j said law head is going to be s and
set up
Barbara, Joe Barton, Nick Pasedena
and, uh, Nate Kraig in Riverside.
Uh, let's sit. It's the white male tour
and going old school here. All right.
Go fuck yourselves. Enjoy
the weekend. You can't, uh,
and I'll talk to you after the Superbowl.
I'll either be in a great mood or a
very subdued mood, one or the other,
but I'll see you on Monday.
[inaudible] the video.
Got It. Okay, great.
A lot of people sent me this
week. It was about these, uh,
these fucking bank of
cock suck. Is there, um,
let's see, what letter is it
here? This isn't the BBC news. Uh,
HSBC imposes restrictions
on large cash withdrawals.
All right. And, uh, so at HSBC,
customers have been prevented.
Some customers I've ever been prevented
from withdrawing large amounts of cash
because they could not provide
evidence of why they wanted it to.
BBC has learnt, isn't it? Learned,
has learnt anyways.
Listeners have told radios for his money
box not to be confused with nature's
box.
Uh,
they were stopped from withdrawing
amounts ranging from five grand or 5,000
pounds,
10,000 pounds.
HSBC admitted it is not informed
customers of the change in policy policy,
which was implemented in November.
The bank says it is now
changed its guidance to staff.
Um, so basically this
guy went down, they said,
can I have my 5,000 pounds that I earned
and I put in this bank for safety?
They said no. He said, can I
have 4,000 pounds? They said no.
And then I wrote one out, I guess one
of the withdrawal slip for 3000 pounds.
And they said, okay, we'll give
you that. Um, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
So they've got a bunch of bad press
and now allegedly they're changing it.
So a bunch of people said, you know,
what's the fucks with these banker cuts?
You know, it's, it's our money,
Yada, Yada, Yada, and all that shit.
I got news for you.
It's not your money.
All right? It's their money.
They print it, it's theirs. Okay.
And your job is to take the money that
they give you for working your ass off
all week,
and your job is to then take that money
and give it back to them or get your ass
into debt with it. Think about
your work all fucking week eight.
What do I do? Even hold money
in your fucking hand anymore.
They give it to you on this
fucking piece of paper. All right?
I know a lot of people rolling
their eyes right now. Okay?
But I got a point at the end of this shit,
okay?
You take it down to these fuckers and
but to them now,
this is the thing,
the reason why it's not like the reason
why they didn't give that person the
10,000 pounds. Do you know why
they didn't give it to them?
It's because they don't have it.
I'm not saying that they don't physically
have 10,000 pounds in the back.
Yes they do,
but they don't have 10,000
pounds available to give to it.
Just some random jackass
who goes, oh, by the way,
I want to take 10,000 pounds
out right fucking now.
They don't have it as well. I don't
know about how it works in England,
but as far as in the United States,
they don't have it for the simple fact
that when if you went down and you
deposit some regular fucking Tom,
Dick,
Harry or Louise and you
deposit 10 grand into a bank,
back in the old days when there was some
sort of rules and regulations governing
these audit controls.
Cunts, when you ran a bank,
you had on your books,
like you could only loan out a
certain percentage of the money
or the bank was in violation. Like, like
say, let's just say to make it easy,
there are $1 million was
deposited into your bank.
You could only at during that
time you could only loan out,
I don't know what the percentage was, but
it was like 300 grand of it, 400 grand.
Um, I forget what the percentage
was, but she, you could, you could,
you couldn't go past a certain tipping
point because God forbid if there was a
run on money and everybody
started withdrawing,
the bank would fail.
Now any bank,
if everybody shows up and tries to take
the money out is gonna fail because you
know, they, they, they loan out a
certain percentage of it all right?
But throughout the years,
they kept pushing that percentage up
more and more and more and more to the
point that they got up to not only can
they loan out 100% of the deposits from
the hard work and the people
that deposit the money in there,
they can actually then create
another $2 million off that million,
something like that. Like,
so if you deposit 10 grand,
they can take your full
10 grand loan it out,
plus another 10 grand off that 10 grand
plus another 10 grand off that 10 grand.
So they basically just invented slash
counterfeited 20 grand that didn't even
fucking exist off that 10 grand.
They got 30 grand loaned out so they
can make the money off that fucking 20%
interest off of that kicking you half
a percent in your fucking account.
And they just sit there knowing
full well at some point,
whatever bubble they're creating is going
to burst. Shit is gonna hit the fan.
You're going to be asked out
and they're too big to fail.
And at worst case scenario that you're
going after a corporation and what are
they? They're just, they're just,
they're faceless corporation is faceless.
They take their bonuses is just sitting
there waiting for John Cougar Mellencamp
to right.
You have fucking song at fucking jackass
aid and they're out there buying a new
fucking yacht. All right?
Did that make sense?
And I know you guys are going to be okay.
Will you full of Shit, blah, blah, blah,
blah. You don't know what
the fuck you talking about.
You sound like a moron. Hey,
I'll take all of that.
But I'm going to tell you this for like
the fucking hundred time in my standup
career when I was in Albuquerque,
I had a banker come up to
me and was laughing going,
I know you hate us. And I said,
listen, am I am more on the podcast?
And they always say no.
They go, no, you're not.
You know this of some factual
errors a little bit here or there,
but basically what you're
saying is 100% true.
I talked conspiracy theory one time
in my own bank as I was trying to set
something up new one my account,
I was talking to a banker about
conspiracy theory and he was talking about
banking. It was talking about
how scary and fucked up it was.
And he was asking me what I plan to do.
What do you think about
gold and silver coins?
What do you think about growing Zucchini?
And I was the most taken,
he's whispering and shit.
I'm telling you. Um,
and I have no solution.
So when I'm really being right now is
a fucking fear monger. But uh, this is,
this is the great thing about
banking is that, you know,
I would say a good 95% of people walking
around with a fucking Goddamn tootsie
pop in their mouth, pulling their fucking
Hawaiian shorts out of their ass, crack,
believe in it. All right? And as long
as they continue to believe in it,
you can kind of exist in the
game drafting behind there.
Um, uninformed. I don't know
what the fucking word is. I'm so,
I'm too stupid to do this, but you
just basically like, I don't know.
I am of the belief that if you can get
a fucking house by one that you can
afford and then pay that
fucker down as soon as you can.
And all of that shit that
people say where they go, oh,
it's not investment because
you go to the dude, fuck that.
Pay Off your fucking house. And then if
the bank fails, you still have a house.
Who gives a fuck if you
paid 700 grand for it,
now it's only worth a hundred grand.
You still have a house.
As much as that sucks,
at least just still have it like
the fucking stock market, right?
You work your whole God damn life.
You stick it in that,
stick it in this over there when
you think you're being conservative,
the thing shits the bed and in the
end you can be left with nothing.
So I am into tangent,
tangible shit. Can you tell?
I screamed whenever I do a podcast the
day after I went to a game or I did a lot
of shows. I sound like I'm going through
puberty again. I apologize. But, um,
I believe in investing in tangible shit.
And don't let your wife or your husband
below goal. We go, kid, we'd go,
we'd go to shave up with a
college education. You know what?
Fuck their college education.
All right. Take out a loan.
Take out a fucking look.
You're paying interest on your house.
Now the amount of money that you're going
to save knocking down your principal
will pay for most if not all
of their college education.
All right? Unless they just go to some
unbelievably expensive school. And your,
I dunno, living in some
little house on the prairie,
Michael Landon smoking a pipe.
Um,
so there you go. So that's why,
that's why when they go down there,
because they,
they're not going to give 10 grand or
10 pounds to the average jackass walking
in there because that starts
fucking with their game,
which is pretending that all the
money is there and that it's,
it's safe and that there's nothing to
worry about and nothing to see here.
So what they do is they pull this shit
and they bully people individually over
in the corner of behind that
bulletproof glass. And they're like, no,
you have to get a note and blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. And most people
like they have a parent child
relationship their entire life.
They come out as a child,
their parents tell them what to do,
what they can and can't do,
when they can eat,
when they have to go to bed and they
go off into the world. You know,
you go to school or going to lunch,
now you have a question,
raise your hand and you
stay in that mentality.
So to the point you have a fucking adult
who earned the money will go into a
bank. You know, God bless this person
who actually fucking was like, no,
this is my money and complained
and brought this out to light.
I think this is the only
person they did that to.
The money's not there man.
Yeah.
Like if you had like two
300 grand in an account,
you decide that you just
want to fucking take it out.
Like if you physically want the money,
if you want to transfer it like
fucking numbers, hit enter,
they'll fucking do that all day.
I had no worries.
But you actually wanted the paper,
like you can't just walk in there and
be like, yes, I'd like my 300 grand.
And they'd be like, okay, I
come out big sex and money.
You got to call them days
if not a week in advance.
And then what they gotta do is
frantically call around in front,
find an armored car with enough of this
paper that isn't worth shit other than
the fact that the guy with the underwear
and his ass still believes in it.
They got to drive that there so they can
physically keep the lie going. Alright,
there you go.
So that's the end of Mike.
My fucking a barroom banking one oh one.
All right.
And uh,
you know,
I don't give a fuck about your opinions
either because I'm not enlightened as a
human being. If you don't agree
with what I said, then you know,
just laugh at me and continue on with
your fucking day because you're actually
helping me out as long as you keep
fucking believe in it.
But I think the day the wave hitting
the beaches is coming soon because,
uh, you know, at least in this country,
I mean the government shut down for
three fucking days and I know it made for
great standup material,
but that is absolutely fucking terrifying.
Every year when August comes around and
we hit the debt ceiling and we just keep
raising it and we just keep
pushing more of shit under the bed,
like eventually, it's not all, I dunno,
that's probably the wrong analogy.
I don't know what the fuck we're doing,
but eventually the shit is
going to hit the fan. So, uh,
I'm not saying I'm going to survive it,
whatever the fuck happens,
but I do have a game plan.
My game plan is to pay off
my house as quickly as I can.
So when the first wave of people
are being brought to the, uh,
I don't know what euphemism they're
going to be using for detention camps.
Um, I figured it'll be like, well,
you can't pay off your house.
We're repossessing the house. So now
we're gonna move you to alternative,
relaxing, living, whatever the
fuck they're going to call it.
At least I won't be in
that first wave of people.
I will have my house paid off and I
will stand there dressed like a court
gesture with my little fancy came going,
but get off my property and
they'll look at me and be like, oh,
look at those little cunt thick
and he has power. All right,
we'll be back for you.
We'll get back for like a month assault.
Let's just get the, uh, let's
get the mouth breathers first.
Let's get the easy people then will weed
out the red cunts and then it'll all be
ours.
Some of that somehow ties
in to how they're trying to
make robots more and more
human. Like, all right,
this is the character shit.
This story right here,
that seems like a victory for the
common man and what it really is,
is this just moving the ball forward on
the development of robots so they could
eventually phase us out.
Um,
and then they could just have robot
people that will never, never complain.
And then of course,
if you watch science fiction movies,
they somehow take over the humans,
which they're not going to do.
They're not going to do that.
All right, we made you all right,
we'll unplug you. We won't fix.
You have dump some water on you.
You know, this is the deal.
Every fucking web designer,
when he builds your
website or rebuild you,
a secure site always builds in
a fucking back door. All right?
So the guys making the robots are
going to do the same fucking thing.
There's no way the Illuminati is going
to have a bunch of robots that are
stronger than them. Don't need to
sleep and all that type of shit.
And like they watch science fiction
movies. These fuckers are science fiction.
How crazy do I sound this week?
I'm actually enjoying every
fucking second of this. Um,
they're going to have a back door,
you know,
somewhere up that robots asked this gotta
be something that they can fucking do.
Some button they have to push.
Um, all right, so there you go.
Was that weird enough
for you? Huh? I'm sorry.
What do,
what do you want from me?
You know,
a fucking weird guy.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it is the
Monday morning podcast from Monday,
January 31st, 2011. How are you?
How are you doing? Really? Oh,
that's good to hear. You know,
I was worried about you that
you know something. You see,
it just goes to show you,
doesn't it?
It just goes to show you that if you sit
around and you think positive thoughts,
you'll have a happy Monday.
Are you having a happy Monday?
Happy Monday to you.
Um, I'm not having a happy
Monday. I fucking, uh,
flew back from Dallas,
Texas,
which is why the podcast is a little
bit late among other fucking tech
knowledgey goddamn reasons cause I bought
a new fucking microphone and I brought
it out to Texas with me and uh,
it just picked up the entire room and
I did a whole fucking podcast and I was
going to upload it like
a good boy midnight.
So even my friends over there and jolly
old England way back over there and
Sweden and even those couple of
constant listening in Mongolia,
what have something on a Monday morning,
wherever the fuck they're at.
And what happened?
I went back and I listened to it and
it sounded like ash and I was like,
I'm not subjecting my listeners to this.
How do you like that? You're like that.
Isn't that a great excuse for being late?
I'm late because I was thinking about you.
I was thinking about your needs.
I think I cared too much.
Um, oh God. I feel like shit.
I forgot to bring my vitamins with
me. Right. I'm such a fucking old man.
Did that mother fucker just
hit the floor down there. Nice.
I think now I'm just hearing
things. Fuck that old guy. Um,
and his balls. Um, yeah, I know.
I forgot to bring my vitamin.
Speaking of old,
I have to bring vitamins with me
when I'm on the road now, you know,
I can't fucking do it anymore. After
years of breathing in that airline food.
Listen, listen to voice right now, right?
A lot of the ladies probably thinks
it's sounds a little bit sexy. It is.
This is what I sound like when I'm
beginning to get sick and I forgot all my
shit. You know, all my
pills on know your man.
All my pills that if fucking take when
I'm on the road, so I don't get sick.
You know, you fly out. I'm
always flying back fucking east,
you know, so then I gotta
get up at six in the morning,
which is really like four in the
morning for me than I do radio.
Then I tried to come back and go to sleep,
but the fucking sun's out.
It can't do it.
Then I do my shows and then I'm fucking
shaking everybody's hands afterwards and
then I fuckin, you know, rub my face,
you know? And next thing you know,
I got road aids, you
know, but it's curable.
It's curable by fucking three shitty days
sitting in your own fucking apartment.
It's my big announcement for the
weak people. I have wrote AIDS,
the first known case of a 2011. It's
early this year. And uh, you know,
it was my fault. I didn't
protect myself. So, uh, yeah,
I'm a little under the
weather this week, so, uh,
but I'm going to fucking bring
it like Jerry Lewis, you know,
who never sat down in his Tuxedo pants.
So I'm laying down right now,
so I'm going to try to bring the fucking
funny, let me tell you about my weekend,
right people. I went out
to Dallas tacy, Dallas,
Texas.
I went out that way and um,
I performed at the new
Improv in Arlington, Texas,
despite the fact that kept saying,
I was in Addison on last week's
podcast podcasts. I was in Arlington.
Did any of you guys accidentally go to
Addison? You have been disappointed,
you would've saw earthquake of
fucking good friend of mine.
Someone I highly recommend you go see
live fucking you want to hear one of
fucking great off the top of his head.
Out The top of your fucking headline
that I saw him do one time. Uh,
what a fuck worthy. We were some
fucking room in the Bronx or some shit.
I can't remember.
It was one of those fucking clubs
were like two days after we did it.
It got shut down because
somebody shot off a pistol in.
There was one of those fucking things,
you know back when I was like,
I'm going to do this. Psycho
is rooms ever, you know,
and then I won't be nervous when I'm
doing Letterman. Well you know what?
It doesn't work that way.
You just get used to doing shitty rooms.
But then when you go to do Letterman
you like, oh wait this, this is,
this is a different kind of pressure.
That kind of pressure is,
well no one's paying attention. How the
fuck can I get these people to listen?
But then it's kind of easy because
it's like, well then that's, you know,
it's supposed to suck. So if you do,
okay, then, then people are like, wow,
that was amazing. But if you do
Letterman, you supposed to do well,
everybody's paying attention.
They got the air conditioner on,
everybody's facing
forward, right, whatever.
So I'm in this fucking room trying to
figure out what the fuck I'm going to say
to try to get,
try to get the crowd going before they
realize how disgustingly white I am,
which they're going to see before
you'd get to the fucking mic stand. Um,
what's his face? Earthquake was on
stage when it was this in Atlanta.
I can't fucking remember anymore.
I'm still whatever.
I was doing some fucking rock.
Right?
And he was up there [inaudible] and he
looked over in the crowd and there was a
woman sitting in there, there's large
woman who was not good looking. Okay.
I'm not trying to be mean,
but her face was a mess.
Okay. I'm talking like a
rottweiler with a dress.
And she had one of those big,
you know,
those African hats kind of looks like
the pope hat, but it's more look,
sort of like a vase and it just
goes straight up. You know,
didn't one of those early rappers
with the giant chunky gold chains,
didn't she wear one of those?
UN I t y that's see unity.
Did she wear one of those?
So anyways,
the girl is sitting in the crowd and
he's in the middle of killing and the
second east, Cesar, you said in
the middle of telling a joke,
he just says he called
her Erica Bod don't.
Yeah,
it was one of the funniest
and meanest fucking things.
I S it was fucking brilliant.
It was right off the top of his head.
But it was so fucking mean because
she didn't say anything. Uh, you know,
she really didn't deserve it,
but it was just what I liked about it
was he didn't point out or he just looked
at her and just to himself when
Erica Bud don't,
and you know the people in that section
new and they just fucking dealt with.
That was what I liked about him
was he, he just said it. He said,
I don't give a fuck that only
people sitting cause you know,
the rest of the crowd could see her,
whatever. So whatever I fucked up.
If you want to wow. The Addison Improv,
you saw earthquake. So there you go.
There you go. Um, but anyways,
I was out in Arlington,
Texas this week to go out
there to the, uh, the Texas,
Oklahoma area with those girls,
with the huge faces in the big heads.
And um,
I saw a lot of them.
So I let her big headed Texas girls and
saw a lot of cutie pies to one way or
the other out there.
They're either fucking drop dead,
gorgeous height doing hi you out.
You want some grits? Gorgeous.
Or they just have these
fucking mount Rushmore heads,
hair teased up cause it's Dallas.
Everything's big in Dallas. Um,
just giant Fred Flintstone fucking heads.
That doesn't stop them
from teasing up their hair.
They look like those Texas girls with
the big heads when they're done with the
eye shadow teasing up their hair,
they look like fucking Nikki Sixx.
Do
you realize the fucking balls I
have to attack how anybody looks?
Do you understand that?
A balding fucking redhead?
Do you want to stay in the level
of fucking balls that that takes?
Um, all right. So anyways,
the first night I fly in and uh,
you know the,
the club out there, he's a little fella,
you know, stands about four foot 11.
He's adorable, you know, likes to dress
a little fucking shiny shirts, you know,
just, just the little fella, you know,
scoots his seat right up to the
steering wheel, you know, sketches,
see, although is, is,
is far up as you could possibly Skoda
seat and his arms are still straight when
he's holding on to the
fucking steering wheel.
I'm just being a Dick and
Casey's listening. Um, so
anyways, he picks me up, right?
And we went right to the fucking
Dallas Mavericks, Houston Rockets Game.
Sat right behind the fucking,
this how great. My weekend was,
sat right behind the
Houston Rockets bench.
Okay,
well actually this is a bench and then
there's the fucking guys who hand them
the water bottles.
Then there was a fucking court
little alley and then there was us.
It was fucking ridiculous.
All right.
And I'm sitting there getting to see all
this shit you don't get to see when you
watch a game on TV,
like a,
towards the end of the fucking
game I saw, uh, you know,
I was one of those deals where
they needed to scores, you know,
don't shoot a three, just get a quick
two and then try and file, do that shit.
So the fucking point guard goes, you know
what? I don't see any other teammates.
I guess it's all up to me.
For some reason he decided to
do this and one bullshit, right?
Fucking one of the most spectacular
missed layups you've ever seen in your
fucking life.
If he did a percentage of the odds
of the fucking thing going and it was
probably even with a good NBA player,
like a 40% shot.
That's what the fuck he took when they
needed, they needed a big score. Right.
Didn't even look, just brought it up.
The court did it all himself. All right.
And fucking missed it. And I immediately
see, you know, cause I'm sitting there,
I saw the coaching staff's reaction.
They just Ah, you know what?
Remember one fucking Slater dropped that
ball and Superbowl fucking 13 and Roger
Star back went ah, just
fucking, that's what they did.
All three of them in unison,
like backup dancers did
the exact same thing. Ah,
just looked over their left fucking
shoulder and then they all went over and
they sat down on the bench like,
well this fucking games over. Okay.
So the rockets quickly foul.
Someone on the Mavericks,
they go up to the line.
I think the fucking point guard did it
cause he's standing up there by half
court and I see him calling over the
coaches. He's going, hey coach, he goes,
should I file?
You want me to file and the coach won't
even look at him and then I see the
player and the coat on the floor
just rolls his eyes like Ash Shit,
I'm going to fucking hear about this
one. Right? That's how close I was.
I'm sitting there, I'm absolutely giddy
to the left of me to the right of me.
I'm sorry, where? Three ladies, right?
They weren't even hot.
They will like sorta hot.
You know they did all this
shit that hot girls do.
They had fancy clothes they had on the
eye liner. They teased up their hair,
but they take just work.
You know?
You know when you watch American idol
and someone can almost sing kind of like
the way I sing picture of the
way. I'm almost there. Listen,
row, row, row your boat
gently down the stream here.
I just said stray right. That's
the kind of good looking. They are.
You are right. Was it wasn't
that bad right up to stray.
That's what happens. Yeah.
That asses in bed, those
titties, not that bad either.
And then you look at their face
straight, you're like, fuck really?
How to fuck are you sitting this close?
So not only were they sitting there,
they weren't fucking paying attention.
This is why I am fucking,
I don't know if the word is racist.
I don't know if it's not racist.
Good looking women is, it's not,
it's not a racial thing.
I don't know if I'm sexist now
cause it's not a woman thick.
It's a specific kind of fucking,
I just,
I fucking beautiful women.
I don't know. You know, you know
when you go to the golf course,
you know what guys tee off in my fucking
mental world versus where the women tee
off in my world, mentally
beautiful women, they,
they got to tee off way back there.
They got to go that extra fucking 30
goddamn yards because I just immediately
assume that you're going to be exactly
like these fucking cops who sit next to
me. They sat there and they had their
fucking stupid noisemakers. Right.
Which is always a sign of a bad franchise.
By the way.
I've said this for fucking years
and for some reason some of you are,
you're not hearing me okay.
If your fans sucks so bad that they have
to give them noisemakers so they can
sound like a fucking enthusiastic crowd.
Okay.
Noisemakers like it's fucking New
Year's eve or some shit. Right?
So this sitting there,
I took a picture of it and it's going
to be up on the MM podcast. By the way,
the girl next to me is holding her two
little thunder sticks in her left hand
hand.
Sorry my voice is fucked up and her
left hand and then she's texting on her
blackberry with their thumb and the
blackberry is wrapped in this little hot
pink fucking would just
annoyed the shit out of me.
And at one point somebody throws an
alleyoop for this monster fucking dunk.
The crowd goes crazy.
She misses the whole fucking thing.
She sets down her blackberry
and then starts clapping.
The thunder sticks together just cause
he hears the crowd and she just goes Yay.
And then put it went right back to
what the fuck she was doing. Yeah,
it shouldn't, it annoyed me,
but it did. It annoyed me.
And then at one point her to two other
whore friends kept yelling over at
somebody who work from the Mavericks.
They were going match, match,
match.
You know they do that in Dallas.
They'll take a one syllable word and
they make, they can make it to like,
I'm going to bag it,
they go me yet.
And I look over and Mitch turns out
to be one of these jackasses who comes
running out like sort of skipping and
running at the same time with one of those
guns and he shoots fucking tee
shirts up into the upper deck.
You know,
you know those fucking guys,
you ever want to just punch someone in
the face more when you see them with
their eyebrows up and they're pointing
up at the upper deck like, Huh,
you want a free tee shirt? Do yet
they do that stupid little skip step,
you know, across the court.
And then they stop, you know,
feet parallel to each other and then they
just stick one hand up in the air and
they, the girls do this and
then they started jumping
in a circle waving. It just,
it's, you know, first of all,
it's embarrassing to watch people freak
out that much about a fucking free tee
shirt. You know, it's like, what
does it fucking 10 bucks. Go buy one
people up there hanging up.
I'm telling you someone's going to
fall out of that fucking upper deck and
they're going to,
it's going to be the dumbest death ever.
And I'm going to laugh and I'm going
to watch it on youtube and I'm going to
have no sympathy for the person cause
you're F it's a tee shirt. So anyways,
he turns out he's one of these guys
and he wasn't really a good looking guy
either, but he works for the Mavericks.
So he has three Sorta hotties. You know,
unfortunately with guys, it's
not how you look. It's, it's,
it's the position you're in in life.
He just doesn't realize it that he could
have got three better looking women.
But you know,
he's too busy looking at is a
imperfections when he brushes his teeth.
That's what I think. Did that story go
off the rails? I think it did match.
Um, then I did my
fucking shows at the, uh,
at the Improv. I had great shows. And then
Sunday I'm sitting around doing not eh,
and a,
the Oklahoma City thunder had a
game against the fucking Miami Heat.
Okay. And I'm like, well,
I live in Los Angeles.
If I wanted to sit down close to see
the Miami Heat at a fucking Lakers game,
I mean,
I'm going to have to fucking shell
out two grand and blow Hugh Hefner.
So fuck it.
I'm going to go up there.
You know what face value for the tickets
were face value of sitting behind the
goal where Chris Bosch should fucking,
uh, Duran got in each other's faces.
I was sitting behind that goal about
fucking, I don't know, 15 rose up.
They yelled really loudly. I could
hear what the fuck they was saying.
You know what face value on
those tickets was 55 bucks
underrated going to a sporting
event in fucking Oklahoma.
All right? Don't sleep on those in
the middle of nowhere. Fucking cities.
It's great.
The cost of living is so much lower.
Ticket prices are fucking lower and you
can sit down low like you're fucking Ben
Stiller. Assump shit. Well,
20 rows behind where he would be sitting
and I'm also on the side and I couldn't
see part of it because the fucking goal
was in the way. But other than that,
it was great.
And I've got to tell you,
underrated also is the
fucking Oklahoma Thunder.
A fucking fans man.
They had great fans and they
had a phenomenal fucking
stadium. It was bare bones,
it was like reverse staples center.
So,
and the tickets were
cheap and people you know,
could afford to go and they had a big
upper deck and they only had one row of
luxury boxes.
So it was loud as hell.
It was way louder than the
fucking staple center. Um,
you know, and I actually liked it
better than the fucking Goddamn Bank,
North Fleet Garden, whatever the
fuck they call that back in Boston,
that awful arena,
those two fucking legendary franchises,
the Bruins and the Celtics. And that's
the fucking arena that you build up.
You go down to Home Depot and you buy
16,000 cinderblocks and you just make a
big fucking square. That's what,
that's what we get. You know,
we had this unbelievable
home ice home court advantage
back in the day. And, uh, I,
I feel like I'm in a food court with them
and that fucking place, so, so anyways,
yeah,
I was sitting right there when they
were talking shit and have identically a
Kevin Durant went off on him afterwards,
said he was one of those fake tough guys
and it was all the big fucking gossip
around the NBA and I was there.
It was fucking site. And uh,
I know you guys think I'm
fucking nuts for doing that shit.
What else was I going to do? Sit
In my hotel room, tell the feature,
act to pick me up and go take me
to get some fucking barbecue. I,
I can't do it anymore, you know, went up
there. You know what's great about that,
that drive from Dallas to,
uh,
to Oklahoma City is it's in between the
two cities when you're in the middle of
fucking nowhere, right? And he'd
go, you go over the Red River,
which I didn't even know I was going to
go to the red river rivalry game last
year. Right. I don't even know
what the fucking red river was.
I didn't know what it was.
What?
Cause they kick the shit out of each
other and there's a river of blood
afterwards.
I had no fucking idea of identity.
That stat river that runs along the south
of the state that gives its, its, its,
its shaped,
right.
So fucking go over that river and then
that's when all the signs about Jay's A's
, they all start coming out. I
took one creepy fucking photo.
This was outside of a gas station
with a fuck is my phone like that?
That's the type of shit, you know,
you're driving down the street. Right.
And you know,
I saw one point,
there were like four crosses on the side
of the road for where like I guess for
people died in a goddamn accident.
I Dunno,
they fucking side swiped an ox or some
shit. I mean it was like in the middle.
It's like the middle of
fucking nowhere. And, uh,
when the hell was that at a time he did
that podcast and I was telling you that,
that guy, oh, I know. When you drive from
fucking Cincinnati down to Nashville,
somewhere in Kentucky.
Can somebody send me a picture of this?
Somebody has the 10 commandments
written out in signage on the,
the outskirts of his, of his, of his
farm. It's really fucking frightening.
Let me see if I can find this. Here I am
scrolling. You know, you get out there.
Yeah, it's all shit about Jesus. Or it's,
or it's a, it's a farm or it's a casino.
Here it is.
Here it is. We pulled over for
gas. What does this sign say?
His blood paid all,
you know, it's like, can
I enjoy my fucking day?
Can I just drive up and
go see a basketball game
without you bringing up the
fact that somebody got tortured to death
so I can somehow make it to fucking
Lala land,
which I'm not going to,
I'm not gonna make it right.
You've heard the podcast,
you think God doesn't have iTunes. I'm
fucked. There's no way I'm making it.
I don't even buy into that shit. You
know somebody last week, you know,
cause I went off on a fucking
Jay star there last week, right?
Fucking bosses son.
Oh fucking twinkle toes himself or
the originator of the Bergen stock.
Fucking look that guy,
you know
who later went on to play bass in
Nirvana, right? Isn't that what Jesus did?
That's the re is he already came
back. You guys missed it. Um,
what was the fuck was I talking about?
Oh,
I was on such a great little fucking
tangent there and I'd bring up Nirvana.
What the fuck did I do
that for? All right, Phil,
you ever do this shit when you can't
remember you talking about that?
You got to back it up in your head. All
right. His blood for you. Oh, I know.
Yeah. Um, yeah. I,
somebody last week sent
me this fucking email.
Let me see if I can find this shit.
It was hilarious because he had in
the subject, in all capital letters,
it just said, answer me. Right.
And I didn't know if it was
somebody fucking around or what,
but it was some dude who was annoyed
by me taking the Lord's name in vain.
Um, there it is. Answer me, Bill.
Here we go. It's from a guy.
I know I don't say names,
but what are the odds that some Jesus
freak would have a first name? Travis.
Um, I wish you would stop using Jesus
Christ's name in vain now. Old g.
Uh,
what do you have against religion anyway,
I think you are confused
about the whole thing.
Attend a good Bible believing church.
Talk to the pastor and
actually listened to them.
I like how he assumes that I talked
to a pastor. I didn't listen. You see?
Did you catch that little passive
aggressive talks in the past?
And once you fucking listen this time,
I would really appreciate it if you would
be open about Jesus and Christianity.
It will change your life. Exclamation
point, guarantee, explanation,
point yet spelled wrong.
He spelled guarantee g,
U. R, a, n. T, and he's just name's
Travis. Garn take of tailing each.
Get in the Jaycees. It's going to change
your life. What do you have against? Well,
let me,
let me read back this and let me give it
the most stereotypical horrific fucking
accident I can. I wish he'd
stop using Jesus' name in vain.
What do you have against religion anyway?
I find oppressive.
That's what I like about it.
I don't like how they use fear.
How they try to scare the shit out of me.
Says the day I'm fucking born and don't
even fucking sit there and act like they
don't. They do. It's fucking annoying.
They don't know what
happens to you when you die.
So stop scaring the shit out
of me. I think you go right
into the fucking ground.
That's what you do and you have fucking,
you make the soil richer. Right?
And then next thing you know, there's a
mosquito flying out of it. Thanks to you.
It works for all of us. Do United
Way, right? That's what I think.
I don't have a problem with religion.
Okay.
I shit on it the way I
shit on everything else.
Why do you just fucking
send me emails when I,
when I talk about a old Jay star there,
you know,
tend to good Bible believing church.
I did. I did it my whole fucking life.
And you know what turned out
they were fucking kids, you know?
Do you understand that Travis?
Do you understand what they did
to society? The amount of fucking,
just people who came forward
and how that's going to
affect the person that they
marry and the way they raise their
fucking kids in the hangups that they are
going to have. That shit is going
to last for fucking centuries. Okay.
And forget about the
fucking Spanish inquisition.
All these fucking wars.
What is wrong?
Like I don't understand these fucking
people who can't see the, the,
the ridiculous level of death
that has been caused because of,
because everybody just trying to fucking,
I'm really preaching right now.
I've got to shut up, but I just, it's just
how I fee fucking asked me. All right.
I just, you know, I believe
in the be a good person,
even though I'm not, you know, and I
can't even say I'm trying to be, I've,
I've quit, I've quit trying to be a
good person. I've been living, uh,
in accordance to the Church of Satan
and I have.
All right.
And I know right now you're thinking,
I'm in here and I'm fucking sacrifice in
a fucking lamb or some shit talking to
old, a fucking LDL below there. I'm
not, that's not what the church is.
Satan is about. That's what the
fuck you guys told me it was about.
And then one day, back in the day, I
had a radio show with young Joe to Rosa,
the teen idols sensation from the
opion Anthony Program. And we,
it was Halloween was coming up.
We said,
why don't we have some of these
satanist people come in here.
Let's see if they could freak us out.
So he was sitting there asking them,
what about the devil and all
that. And they go, yeah, we don't,
we don't believe in that shit that's
organized. Religion came up with that.
We don't believe, we don't believe
that there's a heaven or a hell.
We don't believe in the devil.
We don't believe in any of that stuff.
So I was like, all right, so what do you
guys believe in? And he's just like, uh,
basically doing what feels good to you.
You know,
which means, you know, fucking
bang a bunch of hobbies.
You want a hot fudge Sundae.
You go on your fucking eat it.
If you want peace and quiet,
you don't have kids. You
just, you live for yourself.
That's basically what, that's,
that's their version of it.
So that's what I'm saying.
I've been living for myself.
It's ridiculous. All right.
I play hockey. I played drums. I tell
jokes. I go to fucking basketball games.
I'm not passing any knowledge on to
anybody who half looks like me and half
looks like my beautiful girlfriend.
I've lifted up very selfish fucking life.
So, uh, but I don't need
Jesus. Do I? Travis,
is that what you're yelling right now?
Um, no. That's what I have against it be.
I'm, I'm, you know, I got to make
some of these funny. All right.
I don't have a problem if you're an
organized religion. I don't, but I, I, uh,
I don't understand why a
okay.
I Dunno.
People just don't see how
that everything kind of says the same
shit and then you just have a different
guy that you're, you're saying
it too. And then for some reason,
if the other guys don't believe in your
guy, eventually you end up killing them.
Either one on one face to face or you
let some fuckhead tell you what those
other people are like and how they're
going to get you when they're going to do
all this fucking evil shit.
Right.
And then you go over there
and you fucking kill them.
Why those fucking rich countries
sit there? Yeah. You know,
playing footsie with each other, you
know, resting their feet on bars.
Gold Rolling. That's what they do.
They roll around in cash, you know,
that's what they do. You think,
you think that's what bankers do?
Just sit there just like change.
They just dive into it like a Jacuzzi.
Just coins sitting there. Creepy giggle.
Um, I, what the fuck? I'm tired. So that's
why Travis. All right. That's why I do it.
Cause I don't fucking believe in it.
I don't believe in it.
I don't believe a fucking word of it.
I believe in a higher power.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
I don't know what happens when you die,
but I'm not listening to you or any
other fucking idiot who, you know,
wants to rub one out to his teacher
because you'd do all right. Stop fighting.
Thought you do. Just take it out.
Rub it out. Have a good fucking time.
But your Goddamn Dick,
stop having some other fucking person
tell you what you can jerk off too.
All right.
Yeah.
Oh God. That was Cathartic. That
felt good. I feel good for you guys.
How about you may match, um, match
Travis Dakota. Um, all right.
What are we talking about now?
What do I got here? Move on to, uh,
oh, I gotta read you this shit. Um,
hello to everyone over there
in England. Um, I know,
I keep saying this tour's coming together.
It is, it is coming together. England,
Ireland,
Scotland is fucking,
thing's going to come together and I'm
trying to tack on a Scandinavian tour.
Yeah.
As well.
And then maybe some Australia.
Yeah,
in the, uh, in the fall. All right.
So by all means, I, I love
hearing from other countries.
All right. And I don't give a
shit if you trash fucking America.
I don't give a fuck. I just want
to hear what you think. I mean,
I'm not going to agree
with you on a lot of it,
but let me know what's going on over
your way so I can try to make this thing
that's so specific to Jesus
freaks in Texas. All right. Uh,
this is from England. Uh, [inaudible]
this is some sort of sport.
This is kind of about sports
controversies this week. Um,
I don't know if that was a controversy
between Chris Bosh and a guy,
Kevin Durant. All I know it was,
it was, it was great. You know,
I thought it was awesome. I liked
when they get in each other's face,
they start fucking screaming,
yelling,
and they played the game was
fucking awesome game. And, uh,
I think I became a thunder fan dude.
By the way.
Their mascot is the shit.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
I get, I get why that one? Does it
make sense? You know what I mean?
Like the Phoenix Suns, why they have
a gorilla? I have no fucking idea.
I guess a gorilla like all living things
needs the sun. But other than that,
that's the only connection I make
with a gorilla in the fucking sun.
So, you know, whatever.
San Diego had the San Diego chicken that
made no fucking sense for the Padres,
but the dude was hilarious. So anyways,
this fucking dude for the, a was like,
his name is rumble. Is that his
name? And I began with an R,
I can't fucking remember.
He looks like a where the wild things are.
I'm one of those things.
This fucking dude came out,
head is at half court had his back
to the fucking rim to hand it,
threw it over his head without looking
with the mascot shit on and nothing but
net. All right. And then walked
off the court like it was nothing.
I know he doesn't hit
it every fucking game,
but it was pretty God damn impressive.
And then later on he comes out on a
fucking drum kit in the goddamn costume.
It starts jamming with these fucking,
this, this mini drum line killing it.
And as he's fucking killing it
on the drum kit, the drum kit,
I don't know how starts
going around the fucking, uh,
the mini drum line people.
They're like standing basically where the,
where center court is,
where the basketball is.
And then this thing starts revolving
around it like a goddamn planet around the
sun, like very fast, you know,
to the point that, you know,
almost to the point where he could fucking
fall off and he's still keeping the
beat. The stool was the
shit. Um, so anyways,
how the fuck did I get into that?
Oh,
I know we're talking
sports car traverses here.
So this guy sends me the
sink from England. This is
hilarious. These two guys who,
uh,
basically I,
as far as I can tell that they commentate
for the Premiere League, which is the,
uh, the, the English soccer
league over there for my money.
It's the best one out there. You
know, if my little bit of knowledge,
it's just fucking, you know,
150 years, a ton of 20,
50 years of tradition with some of these,
these teams and fans go fucking nuts.
People get trampled to death. It's, it's
everything that you love about sports,
right?
So evidently these commentators,
um, first of all, they got busted.
They didn't know them, Mike on,
and they was shitting on this lady,
um, who was working on the sidelines,
basically. Not even saying
like, like, you know,
I'd love to fucking bang or basically say,
and she didn't know what
the fuck she was doing.
They just didn't know that
there. Mike's, we're on. So, uh,
now of course one of them has to step
down to the other ones cast to like,
apologize profusely. Here's basically
what happened. You guys got,
I have the youtube videos to you get, you
got to, you got to watch these things.
They're hilarious. I says,
hey bill here in England,
there is currently a very funny
shitstorm surrounding to Sky Sports,
premier league broadcasters. I'm
guessing spot sky sports is like their,
their sports channel, ESPN or
something. Um, so anyways, they're raw.
They're in trouble for sexist comments.
They made about a female official.
See I, I mean I only listened to her
once but I didn't hear them saying like,
Oh look at the tits on her.
They just said that she stunk at her job.
You know,
is it come to that if you just criticize
a woman for doing a job that a guy
usually does that
automatically become sexist?
I don't remember them saying anything
like that. Granted, I'm a fucking moron.
But uh,
I mean when these guys know who
would know better than these guys,
these guys are the guys,
right? So anyways, he says,
a new footage keeps appearing on Youtube
as people seem to be digging up shit on
these guys.
It is well funny as they are a pair of
cozy smug Kuntz who have such great jobs.
Ah, you've got to fucking love
English people. Cozy smug cons.
Can you please send me audio of you saying
that in your fucking accent so I can
play it for my listeners next week.
Cozy smug clients who have such great job.
Is that what a cozy smug countries.
What a fucking tremendous description of
some douche who didn't earn his fucking
positioned sits in a corner
office. Ah, hang on a second.
I got to go talk to that cozy
smug cut down the fucking hall.
Anyways, one has been a one has
been sacked. That means fired. Um,
conspiracy theory is that it's linked
to the fact that he's suing a sister
company newspaper for phone tapping.
Yeah. I don't know what happened there.
Did someone tap his phone?
I have no idea. But anyways,
he goes and the other one was eating
his own balls on the radio today.
Apologizing like mad,
trying to save his career.
I thought this story might appeal to you
as I know you love a good broadcast or
balls up and a bit of bit of woman
trashing thrown in for good measure.
Here are some clips from the story.
Okay.
So he gives me the clips of them making
sexist comments. I'd play it for you,
but a you really as an American got to
listen to it a couple of times to pick up
everything that's saying. Um,
cause they're talking really. Um,
but the best thing is he sent me
this other clip and it's the same two
broadcasters and they're doing,
they're basically speaking over
highlights of women's soccer,
which as far as I can tell,
the quality level is the equivalent of
the WWE NBA during the first two weeks
that it came out. Right.
So they start doing,
they start doing the highlights and these
fucking broads are so bad at play in
football that they just start
laughing all right there.
Do you understand that?
Not in a mean way.
It's what made them laugh
was the level of, of,
or lack of level of quality
of these fucking broads.
The way they were playing the game. They
sucked. You should see this one. It,
he got to watch this video.
I have it up on the MM podcast.com.
This girl, right? The fucking goalie
falls down. I don't know what happened.
She stepped on the stringer for fucking
Tampon. Sorry. That was mean. Um,
she fucking falls down or whatever.
She's horrifically out of position.
So the other girl,
she has basically three quarters of the
net to shoot this little fucking ball
in. None of those. You don't know
shit about soccer. A goal in soccer.
You could drive three of
those double decker fucking
Red London buses through it.
So she's got three. You could
drive to fucking buses through it.
She kicks the ball somehow
she gets underneath it.
This thing fucking shoots up in the air,
hits underneath the crossbar,
comes back out onto the field of play.
And then because of the, the row,
the spin on the ball,
it's somehow by the grace of God,
trickles into the fucking net.
It was one of the ugliest goals ever.
And then the girl start celebrating
like she's fucking Paleo or something.
So I think that that was the high, I can't
remember, cause I only watched it once.
These two fucking cozy smug cons is this
guy says they start fucking one of them
laughs and then the other one has to
continue talking and then he starts
giggling. Ain't I'll fucking immature
guys. Our next thing you know,
they're laughing their balls off and
you know what has saved their job.
If one of these fucking broads can
actually play soccer, it wouldn't,
would stop doing hilarious,
horrific shit on the fucking field or the
pitch or whatever the fuck you call it.
You know? So these guys got
in trouble for that shit too,
which is hilarious to me.
And I'm also thinking why?
That's why girls suck at soccer or
football, whatever the fuck you call it.
See if you suck as a guy and guys
laugh at you, you have two choices.
Either get good so they stop laughing
at you or quit the fucking sport.
You don't have the option
of your thought being me.
To me that [inaudible] stop it and then
everybody has to sit around and pretend
like you don't suck at
what you do for a living
fucking nerve or those broads to get mad.
The fact that that, that, that, that,
that shit is on TV is the level of
play that that actually makes it on TV.
And some guy was 20 times as good,
who can't make it into the premier league
is never going to get on television
these fucking broads get on there.
Right.
And that the level of fucking
play that they put that on.
When does that air over there?
Does it come on right after Benny Hill?
Is it like a comedy Thursday night?
Yeah.
I mean the highlights say literally
should've been playing that way.
We may be back at eight eight eight ticket
that fucking Kazoo Song. So anyways,
you've got to check it out and it's Ah,
it's fucking tremendous.
And I'm not saying that women are
bad athletes, but these women were,
they were horrific.
All right.
I'm not saying Laila Ali could not beat
the living shit out of me. She could.
All right.
And you know what I would expect you
guys to do laugh your ass off during the
highlight of me getting my ass
kicked because I suck at boxing.
I'm terrible at it. You
know, I got a good temper.
I'll fucking spazz out and fucking throw
you on the ground if I can, you know,
and start punching you through
tears. You know, that spare,
that type of shit is what I
used to do when I was a kid.
But I tried taking boxing. I just,
I, I, I'm, I'm not quick, I just,
I don't have that quick twitch muscle
fiber at all and I have a huge fucking
heads, so that's not a good
combination. Slow and having a big head.
You don't want to get into a boxing ring.
Um,
anyways, thank you very much for
sending that. And like I said, yeah,
if you're in any of those,
those countries, a over
there that I, that I go to,
which is basically London, London, I'm
going to war on England. Fucking, uh,
Ireland and Scotland.
Please send me some Australia.
I'm coming your way in any
Scandinavian country. You're right.
As far as the rest of year,
uh, you know, chime in.
If you've got a fucking comedy zone over
there, eventually I'm going to go there.
And it's not because I
give a fuck about you.
It's because I see what the banks
are doing. They're going global,
they're going global, and I'm not going
to get caught flat footed. That's,
that's my,
that's my exit strategy for
when the shit goes down.
All right.
I'm going to go out to van
Nuys and hopefully have a
fucking private jet by then
and I'm going to, as, as the
shit starts burning over here,
I'm going to jump in a Goddamn plane and
I'm flying to another country and I'm
going to be booking gigs.
Hey,
remember me get a mate coming
down for a couple of weeks,
uh, you know, book me in the old fucking
Foster's lager, a fucking comedy tour.
Goddamn bullshit.
That depth charge level beer.
Evidently none of them drink it
over there. Um, oh, by the way,
thanks for Rupert Murdoch. All right,
thank you. Thank you very much.
Jesus Christ. I thought you
guys were cool over there. Um,
you know, Rupert Murdoch is such a
Douchey, almost negates ACDC. Okay.
There's a fucking statement.
You all
right, let's, let's go
onto the next topic here.
I have a splitting fucking headache.
Um, oh, let me get a headache.
You can feel your heartbeat
and your ears. Um, all right.
Oh, here we go. Here's a new topic. This
topic really took off this past week.
The new topic is this racist,
racist, racist, racist.
Um, last week, uh,
we had some people asking some questions
and I can't fucking remember what the
hell they were.
I remember I was saying when I drive
down the street and somebody cuts me off,
I play a game out here in Los Angeles,
a game called a older Asian.
And the person I'm writing with,
we both have to guess.
One person picks all the other
person picks Asian, you know,
and then you pull up alongside and
you take a look and I swear to God,
nine times out of 10 it's
one or the other, you know?
And if it's all Dan Asian,
that's like hitting the green
double zero in fucking roulette.
Nobody went unless you picked it,
unless you said Old Asian. All right.
So I just be like, is that
fucking racist? Right?
Never with somebody chimed in last week,
you said it's actually racist
and age just to say that.
Okay.
So yeah. So I guess I have a racist age
escape. But let me ask you this. Um,
what about the factor that
it's just me and my car?
Aren't you allowed to say
fucked up shit in your car?
Doesn't everybody sort of become like
Michael Douglas and falling down when you
get in your car? Don't you say fucked
up shit. And when I say, don't you,
I mean everybody, not just white
people come on. Black people.
You know what you say about us?
Ah, you know what you say Mexicans?
Huh?
You know what you say?
Everybody knows what everybody says
this stuff. Some more wins. Come on.
You know what you say when you're out
there fucking tackle in a tree and turn it
in. Do a fucking surfboard. Right?
Isn't that what you guys do?
Are those the toughest fucking
people on the planet? I mean,
my whole knowledge of Samoans is
basically professional wrestling,
USC football and uh,
that dude on the Steelers,
I've just never seen a
fucking pussy who's a Samoan.
They just, you know, those are like the
actual, the real three hundreds people,
you know, except they're
not in the snow. You know,
they are a bunch of fatty so why don't
they do with Samoan fucking biggest loser?
Yeah.
That would be the shit. Some fat fucking
Samoan dudes. You bring them in there,
you get them into insane shape
and then at the end of the show,
rather than winning like 200,000,
they just get drafted into the NFL and
they become millionaires. Look at that.
See that people, that's why I moved
out to La, cause I could just,
I can create a show out enough to get,
get it on the fucking air,
but I can create one.
Yes,
I am the idea that is cryptic talk and
I'm not to talk about that failure in my
career. All right, let's plow ahead.
Uh, so here we go. Is this racist? Uh,
this is a question I have.
Is it racist for me to root for a white
running back at this point? You know,
considering the last good one
was like Jim kick and Larry Zaka.
John Reagan's right. Who's the
last? That's a good, you know what?
I don't know the answer to this.
Who was the last white dude
to win the rushing title?
All right, let me think
here. It's definitely nobody,
and I mean nobody before Walter Payton,
there is no fucking way.
It was Walter Peyton was in the league.
Earl Campbell then came
Billy Sims.
Dick then came into the fucking league.
It was always guys and those
guys who were, were just,
they weren't leading the league, but they
was still killing it. Like Joe Cribbs.
You remember him?
Who else?
John Riggins was around them,
but I don't think maybe the
strike season did he wanted,
who else came after that?
George Rogers. Oj Anderson.
Tony Doerr said,
how the fuck did I from Franco Harris,
Rick up church now. He wasn't a rude,
wasn't running back. Wilbert Montgomery.
I've gone right through all the fucking
teams. They all had uh, chuck Muncie.
And you're fine. Jeff. Roger
Craig. Yeah, there was no way,
but they had that psycho white dude.
It was fucking awesome on that team.
I forget his name, but he wasn't leading
the league. Who's the last guy? All right,
let's go pre that.
Any guy who Floyd little gale Sayers,
we're getting back to then
Jesus Christ
as a white running back. Ever done
it. I don't even fucking know.
So that's what I'm saying.
You know, it's like a,
it's like a black people root for
like a black quarterback. I'll let go.
I'll all the fucking Asian people
freak out. When, uh, her deck,
he met Zooey came to town,
you know,
and all of a sudden they give a shit
about the Yankees because they got,
they got, they got one of their
guys on there because there's not,
there's not a lot of Asian guys
in the major league baseball.
I didn't look at them like
they were racist. So can I,
can I be excited about that fucking white
dude who runs for the Cleveland Browns?
Who has that facemash that looks like
the front of a dodge ram truck. Huh?
Let me know. Answer that question. I'm
gonna ask you. I'm going to fucking,
I'm going to work out all my
bullshit on this podcast. All right?
So ever deadly older Asian
is ageist and racist.
That doesn't mean I'm
going to stop doing it.
There's no hate in my heart when I do it.
You know,
like me be justifying it.
Um,
as I sit on a fucking bed
with white sheets on it
for comfort, okay. There's none with holes
in it. I'm not putting it on my head.
All right, so relax. All
right, here we go. Uh,
this is coming Japan,
but these are actually our troops.
We have troops based over there cause
we're making sure that no one takes the
Japanese people's freedom.
That's what we do. We just,
we were so concerned about everybody's
freedom around the world that we, uh,
we muscle our way in and we put a base
there that's like our Starbucks for the
world.
We put a base there.
We just make sure that everybody's all
Hunky Dory looking out for your best
interests.
Um,
fuck. Am I getting sick? Okay. Hey, Belk,
your is it racist segment segment was
the source of much comedy and pain
yesterday for us out here,
stationed in Japan.
Racism is always a source of a headache
and particularly in the military where
great lengths are taken to ensure
that it's not tolerated at all. Well,
that's great. That's a good thing. Uh,
for the most part, they do a great job.
Of course is always going
to be idiots everywhere.
But here's a funny thing that happened
involved involving your previous podcast.
Somehow I'm fucking implicated halfway
across the world. Oh, here we go.
So I'm listening to your podcast.
Admittedly inappropriately at work.
And My coworker who's also
black. All right, let's stop.
Let's look at the stats.
This is a black guy. He's hanging out with
another black guy. Nobody get nervous.
Uh, and my coworker who is also black
and I are laughing at your crazy ass.
Now this guy is definitely black cause
I that how white did that sound coming
out of my voice, out of my mouth at
me. Out of my voice. Sorry people,
I'm laughing at your crazy ass.
Yo,
you did the Belbiq Doba Doba thing about
the Indian reading from one of your
fans letters. Uh, so my guy is
like, yeah, that shit is racist.
And uh,
you know,
he's going to get an email from some
idiot asking is would I click, click,
click racist bill?
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck that is at some sort
of African accent. He goes, I mean, oh,
I keep fucking that thing up.
I actually did this podcast the
other day and I messed that up.
Let me just read this entire quote. I'm
gonna read it as white as possible. Uh,
so my, my friend whose African American
said, yeah, that shit is racist. You know,
he's going to get an email from some idiot
asking is bullied Boulay click, click,
click racist bill. I mean, I know
I'm not racist, so I don't know.
I just don't know.
Um,
here's where it goes.
Twilight zone or warming passing by in
the hallway was evidently offended by my
coworkers.
Insensitive impression of African dialect.
So that is African. All right.
[inaudible] something like that.
Shaka Zulu. Right. Um, so she will,
this coworkers just walking by is this
dude's talking about my podcast and she
gets offended by the black guys.
Impression of an African.
Alright. It's evidently it's a
white lady who gets offended.
He tried to explain to her that he was
using it as an example and even offered
to play back the portion of the
podcasts that it applied to,
but it seemed a bit like
she was determined to take
advantage of this situation
to make some sort of point.
So picture this visual bill,
a white woman is sitting there preparing
a statement about a black guy making
racist comments about black people
in front of another black guy,
myself and all of this being presented
to the section commander who happens to
be Japanese American.
I can't,
I'm sitting there as a
witness biting my lip,
trying not to laugh because I swear
I could see on the command his face.
He was like, dear baby Jesus,
what the fuck is going on?
I'm like,
he was trying to blink himself out of
the room and this entire situation.
So we'll see where this goes
in the upcoming weeks. Um,
he sent me another email and
the, uh, the commander there,
the Japanese American commander told
the African American to handle it within
his, uh, he just handled
himself with the, uh,
Caucasian American. There was that
politically correct enough? Um,
you hit it on the head in
your last podcast as far as
it's what's in your heart
most times in regards to whether or not
something is racist. Uh, people know,
fuck all that. Oh, I
was not aware. Shit. Uh,
if you say something or do something and
then you wonder if it's racist or not,
chances are it probably is.
Slash was if the first thing
that comes out of your mouth is,
I'm not a racist or anything,
but I already know I'm in
for some bullshit. This, uh,
the saying that anything you
say, oh, what's that saying?
Anything you say before the word
but is automatically racist.
And that is true at least 98% of the time.
And nowadays the Internet has just given
people mostly idiots and cowards of
voice of anonymity for shit like
that. Yeah. That's something I really,
I really depressing is the fucking level
of a racist comments or fucking youtube
like that pussy shit where no one
can see you. No one can get you in.
You're talking to all that
fucking shit. And uh, I dunno.
That's depressing. It's really depressing.
Anyways, uh, on the flip side, the Sh, uh,
is the shit some black people
say about any other race.
Ah, Shit. Sorry. I was doing really
well reading out loud this week.
When we blow through this last paragraph,
I swear to God and I'll end the torture.
Uh,
on the flip side is this shit some black
say about any other race offensive.
Oh, that's not my fault. He
wrote that about any other
race, offensive and racist.
Of course. Anyone that says no
is being an idiot. I'm a realist.
It's why I don't tolerate any extra hip.
I grew up around black guys and
I have an Nwa cassette tape,
white guys saying the n word around me.
It's also why you never hear me say
cracker or any other ethnic slur even in
just, um, so anyways, he's got a
question. He said, is it racist?
When you hear a story about an athlete
shooting someone in a strip club and you
assume you know what color he
was, maybe to some, is it racist?
When I hear about a polar bear slapping
the shit out of someone's kid or a video
of a guy shitting in a girl's mouth.
And I'm pretty sure I know what
color all of those people are not.
Oh, I'm pretty sure I know what color all
of those people are not. Um, just my two,
2 cents. While thank
you for chiming it. Um,
that's funny that you bring up that whole
new story because someone else wrote
in to ask me if they thought that this,
if this was like a racist game, they said,
Bill,
I like to play a little game similar to
your Asian or old person driving game,
except my game involves the evening news.
It's called beaner black guy or
crazy ass cracker. Just to clarify,
I am Hispanic parentheses,
Latino,
Mexican or whatever other dumb
ass term someone has come up with.
So saying beaner is okay,
see now this is why I
wanted to do this segment,
which is the exact fucking reason. Okay.
He says, beaner black guy and cracker.
All right? And he goes, I can
say meaner because I'm Mexican.
Well then why can you say
cracker ass cracker, right?
It's because I'm white and no
one gives a fuck about that one.
See what I'm saying?
This is something that I learned from
doing stand up in front of all different
kinds of people. That's what I learned.
I learned that everybody, basically,
it's not that they're selfish, they, they
just, they look out of their own head.
You can't help but do that. So you just
see shit from your own perspective.
Like one night I was doing this gig right
down at the old Boston Comedy Club in
New York City. And one of the acts
that was going up was this, uh,
was this, I think I told
this story before, it was a,
it was a comedy team is
this Asian Guy and girl.
And they went up there and they
did this fucking rap. Okay.
And they went up there and they stuck
their teeth out like they had buck teeth.
And then they put,
you know,
those glasses that you can put on those
joke ones that make your eyes look Asian.
They had though they're Asian
and yet they still put those on.
And then the other guy had on a,
uh,
a fake gold chain with a fucking
fortune cookie hanging off the thing.
So I'm sitting there looking at him
before they're going up going, oh man,
this isn't going to fly. This isn't
going to fly with this fucking crowd.
This is basically, uh,
what do you call that shit?
What was that shit back in the
day and old time, Hollywood,
it was almost like Asian black face.
Like what they were doing was fucking,
was ridiculous. I was thinking
that black people watching it,
we're going to be like, just all
the shit that they've been through.
We look at and be like, what the
fuck? Why are they these fucking,
why are they selling out their own
fucking race? This is horrific.
This is fucking horrific.
And they didn't,
that act went up there and they fucking
destroyed and everybody their balls off.
They thought the fortune cookie thing was
fucking hilarious. And I was just like,
yeah, people, I don't know. Maybe it's
cause they're shitting on their own race.
What the fuck you supposed to do? I Dunno.
I just found that shit. Fascinating.
So what does that pertain to?
What the fuck? I just said,
I don't know if this colt
medicine's kicking in. Let
me finish this. So anyways,
this is basically what this
guy does. He says, uh, uh,
just to clarify [inaudible] okay,
now this game started because I hate
watching the news and no matter what I'm
watching sports center,
usually my wife will want to change it.
I'm so naturally being
the asshole that I am.
I had to figure out a way to ruin it for,
um,
so what I do is turn away from
the news whenever they begin,
begin explaining the crimes are events
of the day based on the description of
the crime or event and how it
was committed or performed.
I yell either beaner black
guy or crazy ass cracker.
Do that actually sounds like
a fun fucking game. Well,
I wouldn't say crazy ass cracker. I
would just say fucking white dude. Um,
example news report says what
I say. Bainer no, I wouldn't.
That's one of the worst ones ever.
Beaner it's got no ring.
It's got no flow. That must've been a
bad day with white people. You know,
usually where a lot more
creative than that, you know,
named me after her fucking vegetable
isn't a vegetables that have fruit.
What the fuck is, I don't
know. Fucking anyways to plow
ahead. Example News report,
it says a man was stabbed
and I yell out painter.
I know it's being it because we Mexicans
can't afford guns and still pay for our
legal extended family members. We have
living with us and our two bedroom house.
If the news report says a drive by
shooting, I yell Black Guy, come on.
Do I really have to explain
the reason behind that one?
And of course if I hear the suspect
had body parts of his victims in the
refrigerator,
fucking crazy ass cracker.
It's because of this game that my
wife has stopped watching the news all
together and I now have peace and
quiet to enjoy my top plays of the day.
Fix On sports center. Well good for you.
Good for you. And I'll see that something.
I don't, I don't think that
that's racist because what?
You don't have any hatred
towards any of those groups.
What you're doing is you're actually,
you don't want to watch the news.
It's fucking depressing.
You want to watch sports and then she
puts on a bunch of depressing shit.
And what are you going to do?
Sit there and get depressed?
Or are you gonna fucking
entertain yourself? So you
turn it into a fucking game?
It's actually a a, you know,
I'm not offended by it.
I think that's fucking funny and
there's a lot of truth to it.
Much as I hate to admit some
of the shit yet we're fucking
body parts. Those scat
videos, I don't think,
I've never seen a black guy in a scat
video. Not that I've fucking, you know,
watch those things.
But I have done the opiate Anthony show
and occasionally a weird video will come
up.
Eh,
Jesus. I have scar tissue
in my brain from that show.
A couple of times they add, they
brought up one video one time. I,
I'm not even gonna describe it.
I just refuse to watch it and it still
haunts me and I never even fucking site.
Um, and I'm not talking about two girls
in one cup because I did see that one,
but they had another one
where a guy had a jar.
And he did something with that jar
that you didn't think was natural.
He somehow did it. And then the, uh,
I'm gonna use an engineering term
here. The, the structure failed.
The structure failed.
Um,
the outside pressure was too much for
the structure and at which point it
reached a breaking point and it
failed the job. Broken the dude's ass.
Okay.
I'm like,
okay.
And I refused to look at the video and
all I heard was everybody else in the
video screaming in horror as this guy
tried to avoid a trip and embarrassing
trip to the emergency room and clear
up the situation himself. All right,
I'm sorry.
That's what the most disgusting things
I've ever described in the podcast.
Let's plow ahead. Um, oh, here's a
guy responding to the da Ba da Ba.
Um, is that racist? Um, anyways, so yeah,
Indians aren't big white people fans
because the British controlled their
country for hundreds of years.
See that once again. See,
we all can make ignorant statements.
So then you should hate the English.
Why do you hate all white people?
See that we're all just as dub.
Oh God dammit. This, this
is, this is enjoyable. All
right. It's plow ahead here.
Um, you know what's some English
guy said to me the other day,
I was out in Dallas. This guy from
Manchester was fucking hilarious.
He said to me,
uh,
I was talking about the
fucking revolutionary war
and I wasn't even trash in
England. And when I brought
up the revolutionary war,
he goes, oh yeah. He goes,
he goes, how's that tax free
country working out for you?
Oh, that was such a fucking
good one. I was, I had nothing
to say. I was like, yeah,
yeah, absolutely. Fucking right. The rich
people fucking stirred up the morons.
They kick the fucking British out and
then the rich people just picked up where
the British left off evidently. Alright.
Plowing ahead. Indians racist. All right.
Anyways, Bill. So yeah,
Indians are big white people fans because
the British controlled their country
for hundreds of years. Um, even as much
as I gave you shit. I understand that.
So if you see me getting off the boat
with my fucking Goddamn red hair, right?
You're just thinking,
I'm another God damn person coming
over there to fuck over your country.
I get that.
He says,
the worst part is that it was
a company that ruled them.
The British east Indian India trading
company pretty much controlled the country
using soldiers to keep
the Indians in line.
There was at least one really bad massacre
where in a British general had his
troops opened fire on a group of,
and I don't know how to say this,
and I'm not going to
disrespect these people.
S I k h s is that seeks,
I have no idea.
I'm just, okay, so open up in a fire.
These a group of these people
just for being in a group,
something like 2000 people died,
including many women and children.
Then Gandhi came and
peacefully drove the Brits out.
Just thought I'd let you know,
Dude, you are just like me.
You overheard that shit or
you read about it. 20 years.
That was the most vague description of
a horrific event I think I've ever read.
There was at least one really bad massacre
where a British general had a troops
opened, fire on a group, a group,
and like 2000 people died. Let me ask
you guys, other guys have question here.
The other people listen to this podcast.
When you think of a group of people at
what number do you stop calling it a
group before it becomes a crowd,
you know,
before it just becomes mass fucking
murder. I mean, for me, uh, uh,
a group of people's about seven or eight,
you get up to around 15.
That's a crowd. 2000 fucking people.
Are you referring to the, uh,
I actually read a little bit about that.
I bought this book on a Winston Churchill
and Gandhi because I wanted to read
about some other history other than the
same fucking stories that they gave me.
It's like church, you know,
I heard all, all above Jesus.
They read Jesus diary to me for
the first 17 years of my life.
It got fucking tired of it. I want to
read something else. So I read. Yeah,
there was, I was a lot worse
than that. Something I, I
remember reading about this.
I'm going to give you a vague
description of what I remember.
This is classic for my podcast,
cause nobody knows what the fuck
they're talking about. See this,
this is how we're all
coming together. Um, yeah,
the British were fucking over the Indian
people and Indian people did something.
They finally fucking snapped and they
went off and they did something really
violent to, uh, some of the
British people who were over there,
including women and
children, I believe. And uh,
they went say, you know,
we'll say one to 10 evil.
They went about five and
then England said, Oh yeah,
we'll fucking show you what Eagle Evil is.
And then they came back and they went 15,
and they were like,
fucking burning people alive. They just
went around just, just shooting everybody.
Um, which is what you have to do
when you fucking occupy a country.
You have to commit fucking genocide.
That's the only way,
which is why you shouldn't do it.
You know?
It's why you shouldn't fucking invade
another country because they ain't fucking
leaving, played fucking leave.
And so Adam, what the fuck?
You know what this is like,
that's part of a whole nother
big describe a discussion.
I shouldn't even have
fucking brought it up.
But the only occupation I've ever seen
that ever fucking work was in this
country.
And the reason why it worked was because
we weren't leaving and we fucking
committed genocide that Ciri.
And I'm not for that on any fucking level,
which is why when I look around the
world and I see certain people in certain
areas, I'm not surprised with
what the fuck's going down.
Cause that's what always goes down.
It's what always fucking goes down.
It's fucking, uh, I dunno.
It's fucking, it's evil.
It's pure fucking evil. Um, so anyways,
a youtube videos of this week, they,
you know, some, a lot of that
stuff deserve a lot of justice.
I'm a lot more justice than Apophis
a little under the weather here. Uh,
youtube videos of the week,
um, kid dunks himself now,
those douchebags who come out on the
court after the black guys of all fucking
dunk from the foul line.
And then the white guys come out with
trampolines to try to roughly duplicate
what you just saw.
This fucking kid,
he jumps too high and he goes
through the fucking hoop.
I got to give it up to the
kid though, man. He fucking,
he didn't go right through the hoop.
He was part of the way through the hoop
and he realized that there was someone
coming behind them. So rather than
fucking tried to go out again, he just,
he just went right through.
The hope was a very heads up fucking play.
A funny video or this one's great,
funny video making fun of Lebron
commercial with Brett Farve.
Um, this fucking guy in this
video doing Brett Farve. He,
not only does he look like him,
not only does he sound like I'm,
he even even gets the facial expressions
down of Brett Farve. It's fucking great.
Um, and I made fun of Djs last week. So
this guy sent me a DJ video to watch.
It's called, uh, from Kid Koala. Skanky.
Pankey. I get it. It takes a lot of skill,
but I don't ever want to listen to
it again. Um, oh. And then somebody,
a few, about a month ago I talked
about drop d tuning, how that was a,
that's how you make the devil.
Your bitch is you write a song and drop
d tuning and I've never heard a song
that did that,
that sounded bad and drop d tuning.
So he sent me another video
of a great song and drop d,
which is a nirvana negative creep.
I guess it's in that. I didn't,
I didn't fucking look. Let's get to
overrated. Underrated. All right,
this fucking podcast. What the Hell is
going on here? What are we up to here?
Hour and six minutes. Jesus, let's
wrap this up. Let's go real quick here.
Underrated local bands there.
Always way more talented than actually
and actually write and play their own
music that should be heard instead
of all the popular lady Gaga,
Beyonce bullshit. Go out to a bar
and enjoy the live music. I agree.
Overrated horoscopes,
whore a scopes.
Why do people think that some asshole
interprets the planets and stars and stars
position is a good flow
influence on their lives.
You could literally say whatever you
want is a justification for your actions.
I'm not as slot. I'm a Scorpio and
Venus is aligned with the Milky Way.
No, you're a slut because you fuck a
lot of people. All right. Stop blaming.
The heaven should count.
Um, all the people, um,
who freaked out because they thought
their horoscope was different due to the
new 13th sign can shut the fuck up.
If you read further than one paragraph,
you discover your sign is different.
If you were born when they announced it.
Um,
I don't even know what the fuck that
means. I know recently that they, uh,
somebody tried to say that everybody
signed was wrong and I guess people freak
the fuck out. Um, oh,
here's another racist one.
God Damn, I was to read this next week.
Everybody chimed in on that topic.
Do you guys have time to listen to me?
Give somebody some of my bad advice? Well,
of course you do. If you doubt,
just shut the fucking thing off.
I'm not holding you hostage.
Um, let's see here. Bill.
Uh Oh, this guy says
[inaudible] love the podcast.
You're always answering questions, giving
out relationship advice about, you know,
between men and women.
So I figured I'd switch it up here and
actually asked for your advice about a
band situation.
I'm pretty drunk so I apologize in
advance if my punctuation is incorrect.
I joined an established band on base
about three months ago and spent the first
couple of weeks busting my hump learning
tunes to open for a semi well known
nation, nay national touring band.
Since then, I burned about three dozen,
so I've learned about three dozen
songs in gigged once or twice a week.
Some of them were high profile shows
opening for some semi famous bands in
theaters, seeding a thousand to 1200
people. It's been a good steady work,
but I should known that there was a catch
after the fifth gig. I finally said,
do what the fuck's up with the money?
Ask The bandleader and he said that all
the money goes into a band fund to pay
for a recording of a CD.
I never agreed to that when I joined
the band. So I was like, what the fuck?
I asked what happens if I quit the band
before we record the CD? And he said,
all the money goes to recording whether
or whether or not I'm in on it or not.
Naturally, I got pissed. Yeah, Dude. What
the fuck? After a big balls out fight,
he finally offered to
pay me 35 bucks per gig.
Nobody has it harder than musicians
other than fucking strippers or whores,
prostitutes, sweatshop labor.
All right. Whatever. It's
still fucking rough gig. Uh,
we usually get paid between 400
to 600 bucks. So I said, no,
I should get paid in equal one
fifth of whatever the band makes.
I'll see you guys get 400,
six to 600 bucks a night. Yes,
you should get like a hundred
bucks a cell. Right? And
he's trying to give you 35.
I like this guy standing his
ground. Um, but this shit bird says,
since I haven't been in the band as long,
I don't deserve an equal share.
Basically they want to
treat me like a hired gun,
but don't want to pay me fairly.
Plus I come to find out the old bass
player quit in a huff with gigs on the
books because they were fucking of Oh
fuck. Fucking them all over on money too.
I've been a professional,
reliable.
I learned all the fucking songs
they showed up at Ben on time.
And on top of all that, they're asking
me to designed posters, stickers,
a press kit and go out and book more gigs.
I feel like I'm being taken
advantage of all the, um,
what, what do I give a fuck if we record
a CD? None of these songs are mine.
All I have invested in it is my time.
It's good steady work and play pays,
sorry.
It's good to get steady
work and played big gigs,
but we're not playing
too faggy chick music.
So it's not like I'm even getting laid
out on the gigs and there's always a
shortage of bass players in the world.
So I can have a couple of the bands.
I've got a couple of other
bands nipping at my heels,
but none of them are as high profile.
You don't dump your girlfriends.
He got another broad to bang on the side.
So I feel like I should keep playing
with these twats to gain a reputation and
then quit as soon as something better
comes along. So what do you think? Uh,
I think you're absolutely right.
All right. Two things. One,
never go into another situation unless
you've hammered out how the fuck you're
getting paid. Don't just be like,
yeah, I'll do it. Good. You're hired.
You got immediately talk about pay
because then after four or five gigs,
you're already in, you're
committed, you've got time invested,
and now they've got you by the Bulls.
So don't do that again.
And as far as advice with the band,
I would just do exactly
what they're doing.
They're doing what's best
for them in fuck you.
So do what's best for you and fuck them.
All right.
If staying in that band is going to
help you in the future by being on those
high profile gigs that I'd stay in the
band and when something better comes
along. See Ya. Right. But, uh,
if getting the fuck out and that some
of these bands that want to fucking play
with you actually seem like they're
going to go somewhere, you know,
you might want to do that
instead, but it's up to you.
But like I said, choose, go,
go church of Satan there. Do what's good
for you. Don't be a martyr like that. Uh,
like that long haired dude there. All
right, that's the podcast for this week.
Thanks everybody chime in.
I apologize if this one was a
little bit scattered brained. I uh,
I'm really feeling this fucking God damn
head cold coming on. So, uh, that's it.
Have a good week and that's it. Uh,
who do you like in the Superbowl?
Wait a minute. This always happens
to me all. He's got to wrap it up.
Who are you like in the Superbowl? You
want a prediction? I, this is what I say.
Take the Steelers in the over. All right.
Because I think in general people are,
people gonna think the packers
are going to win. You know,
I haven't watched any
ESPN for some reason.
I think the PR people think
the packers are going to win.
Whoever the fuck they say is going to
win better on the other team and bet the
over. Because I think that they're
gonna think that, you know,
because of the defenses, if
it's going to be this, you know,
all schools smash mouth football type.
No. Like those you, oh, I put ball.
I think they're going to,
it's going to,
everybody thinks it's going to be that
and it always goes to the other fucking
way. So, uh, that's it. Um,
that is the podcast for this week. Uh,
good luck to both teams in the super bowl.
You know, they, they,
I was in Dallas and actually said some
guy went on TV and said that they were
10,000 strippers short.
You know
what a sad state of affairs,
10,000 strippers, short game.
You believe people still go to
titty bars unless you go into one.
We can actually get one rubbed out.
What is the fucking point?
You know what I mean?
Then what do you do?
Do you go to an ice cream parlor and
having fucking put ice cream on a spoon?
You open your mouth.
They put it in your mouth.
Then right as you go to clamp down,
they pull it back out again.
Is that what the fuck you do?
Overrated titty bars.
There's no fucking reason to go to him.
You just get frustrated.
Then he'd get drunk and then
the end is some sort of fight,
and then that guy from the titans
comes in and somebody gets shot,
and then he just says, I didn't do it.
And then he plays for like the Falcons,
right? Isn't that how it went
down? I don't fucking know. Uh,
all right.
You know what?
Why don't I go fuck myself so
I could end this fucking thing?
All right.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].